bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat pour l'ouverture de la
session extraordinaire sur fond de
grogne des parlementaires
il s'inquiète de l'avalanche des textes
qui l'ont examinée à la demande du
président de la république et du premier
ministre jean marc ayrault
il faut dire que d'ici au 25 juillet
date des vacances parlementaires
l'agenda des députés et des sénateurs
est bien rempli et beaucoup se disent
usé par cette inflation législatif qui
paradoxalement était dénoncé par la
gauche du temps de nicolas sarkozy or
aujourd'hui après un an de quinquennat
françois hollande avait déjà fait voter
39 loi nicolas sarkozy à la même époque
avait fait voter lui 42 loi alors cet
après midi jean pierre bel le président
du sénat devrait à son tour dresser un
bilan de la session ordinaire avant
d'ouvrir officiellement cette session
extraordinaire qui je vous le rappelle
sera donc particulièrement chargée pour
les sénateurs puissent qu'ils auront à
examiner un texte sur la transparence de
la vie publique la réforme du csm le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature ou
encore le projet de loi visant à lutter
contre la fraude fiscale et la grande
délinquance financière
sans oublier deux séances de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement et de débats
cet après-midi un débat concernant
l'avenir de la politique agricole
commune mais aussi jeudi un débat
d'orientations budgétaires alors sans
plus tarder la direction à l'hémicycle
du sénat pour suivre cette séance bonne
après midi à tous la séance est ouverte
mes chers collègues je rappelle qu'au
cours de la séance du 18 juin dernier il
a été donné connaissance au sénat du
décret de monsieur le président de la
république portant convocation du
parlement en session extraordinaire à
compter du 1er juillet 2013
je constate que la session
extraordinaire est ouverte le
compte-rendu analytique de la précédente
séance a été distribué
il n'ya pas d'observation le procès
verbal est adoptée sous les réserves
d'usagé chers collègues
j'étais très profondes le très profond
regret de vous faire part du décès de
notre collègue jean louis lorrain
survenu le 27 juin il fut sénateur du
haut rhin de 1995 à 2004 elle était
redevenu depuis le 7 mars 2010 je
prononcerai son éloge funèbre
ultérieurement
mais je tiens d'ores et déjà à saluer sa
mémoire au nom du sénat je souhaite
exprimer notre sympathie et notre
profonde compassion à sa famille à ses
proches et au groupe ump
je vous propose d'observer un instant de
recueillement
vous remercie
conformément aux articles 325 et 179 du
code électoral monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur a fait connaître qu'en
application de l'article du code
électoral 320 madame françoise bogue est
appelé à remplacer en qualité de
sénateur du haut rhin
monsieur jean louis lorrain décédé le
jeudi 27 juin 2013 son mandat a débuté
le vendredi 28 juin 2013 à 0 heure au
nom du sénat tout entier je lui souhaite
une cordiale bienvenue
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
comme le veut notre tradition je
voudrais revenir avec vous sur la
session ordinaire qui vient de s'achever
au cours de laquelle le sénat a beaucoup
travaillé nous avons en effet tenu je
vais être précis 866 heures de séances
publiques auxquelles il faut ajouter les
quelques 1337 heures de commission et
les 280 une heure de délégation nous
avons ainsi dépasser la référence fixé
par l'article 28 de la constitution de
120 jours avec 122 jours de séance ce
tas a été partagé de façon équitable
le partage défini par la révision
constitutionnelle du 23 juillet 2008
n'est pas tout à fait celui qui avait la
préférence du sénat nos collègues qui
avaient travaillé sur cette révision
s'en souviennent il conduit cependant un
nouvel équilibre entre les projets du
gouvernement et les propositions de lois
mais aussi entre le temps consacré à
légiférer et celui dévolu aux contrôles
aujourd'hui nous sommes nombreux à
relever les difficultés des lacunes même
d'un tel fonctionnement qui nous conduit
à traverser des périodes d'intense
activité parfois à la limite de
l'acceptable pour un bon travail
législatif suivi de semaine beaucoup
moins chargée qui entraîne une faible
mobilisation
pourtant les projets du gouvernement
occupent eux près de deux tiers du temps
de séance publique
mais le troisième tiers consacré aux
propositions et au débat souhaité par
les sénateurs s'est révélée
particulièrement dense puisque
l'initiative sénatoriale a constitué 51
% des sujets mis à l'ordre du jour le
sénat a ainsi examiné 48 proposition de
loi dont 35 d'initiative sénatoriales
pour seulement 35 projets de loi
39 texte sans compter les 34 promotion
internationale ont été définitivement
adopté par le parlement dans huit
proposition de loi sénatoriale
pourtant sur des sujets
divers tels que l' alerte dans les
domaines de la santé de l'environnement
le transfert des biens sectionnaux
commune ou la réforme de la biologie
médicale
une loi sur cinq prend ainsi naissance
au sénat grâce au dialogue approfondi
entre les deux assemblées pour que les
propositions sénatoriales deviennent des
lois de la république
encore faut-il que la navette le suivi
que la navette suivent perdant ce qui
suppose une vigilance permanente afin
d'assurer la bonne fin de la procédure
législative
par exemple pour l'introduction de la
notion de préjudice écologique dans
notre droit ou l'instauration d'une
journée nationale d'hommage à la
résistance les groupes politiques ont
pris une part active dans l'inscription
des initiatives sénatoriales discuté en
séance plénière au total 75 % des sujets
ont été proposées par les groupes 25%
par les commissions au sein de ces
initiatives le pluralisme s'exprime
pleinement la répartition du temps
donnant à chacun la possibilité de
contribuer au débat avec le ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
la conférence des présidents a joué un
rôle déterminant de pilotage de l'ordre
du jour on pourrait dire d ordre du jour
du sénat de manière à concilier les
priorités gouvernementales et
l'impératif d'un débat approfondi et
pluraliste cet ordre du jour loin d'être
figée ou rigides a pu évoluer au gré des
priorités gouvernementales ou
sénatoriales ainsi le sénat à inscrire
dans une semaine sénatoriales le premier
projet de loi sur la réforme
territoriale et le gouvernement a fait
preuve de réciprocité pour répondre aux
souhaits des sénateurs avec des bases
européen ou sur le bilan annuel de
l'application des lois
la session 2012 2013 a d'une certaine
manière confirmer ce que j'appellerais
la force du bicamérisme plus de la
moitié des 39 texte adopté défini
tivement l'ont été au fil de la navette
et le tiers à la suite d'un accord de
cmp
si loi essentiellement de nature
financière ont fait l'objet d'une
lecture définitive à l'assemblée
nationale certains y voient le signe
d'un affaiblissement du rôle législatif
du sénat mais c'est une situation qui
est régulièrement intervenus dans notre
assemblée depuis 1958 le au sénat la
majorité a rarement eu les moyens de
s'imposer mais souvent l'obligation de
se construire dans notre assemblée les
scrutins se suivent et ne se ressemblent
pas car nos échanges permettent souvent
de trouver le chemin du compromis
lorsque bien sûr la volonté existe à cet
égard le travail accompli récemment par
la commission de la culture et les
différents groupes sur la refondation de
l'école et sur l'enseignement supérieur
est exemplaire
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer la
contribution des groupes politiques de
l'opposition et de la minorité qui n'ont
pas bloquer le processus
mais contribuer à l'amélioration des
textes de la même façon que le sénat de
l'alternance au lendemain du 1er octobre
2011 avait pleinement joué le jeu
institutionnel pour mettre en oeuvre son
programme le gouvernement a eu recours à
la procédure accélérée pour 31 texte ce
chiffre élevé a eu pour effet de réduire
le délai moyen d'examen des textes de 9
à 5 mois
si cette procédure est utile pour
assurer un examen rapide
les textes jugés prioritaires elle est
courte prématurément le dialogue entre
les deux assemblées
au risque de compromettre les chances
d'un accord
c'est d'ailleurs après l'échec de la
commission mixte paritaire que l'accord
a été trouvé en nouvelle lecture sur le
projet de loi sur l'assemblée des
français de l'étranger afin de tenir le
rythme des réformes le sénat est
parvenue un meilleur équilibre entre le
travail en commission et en séance le
travail collectif des commissions a
ainsi joué un rôle essentiel pour
assurer la clarté et la cohérence du
débat
en séance plénière le temps de séance
est une denrée rare et précieuse aussi
rien ne doit être négligé pour préparer
un amant le travail au sein de
l'hémicycle mot débat de contrôle
peuvent y contribuer le temps consacré à
ces débats a progressé de 27 %
atteignant 205 heures avec 47 débat
d'initiative sénatoriale dont quatre
débats préalables à des réunions du
conseil européen
le redéploiement des activités de
contrôle répond sans doute à une
aspiration et à une nécessité
démocratique ce soit au total 124
chantiers qui ont été engagées au cours
de la session ordinaire dont 62 actions
conduites par les commissions
permanentes 23 par la commission des
affaires européennes et 27 par les
délégations et l'office votre assemblée
ne peut que se réjouir d'assumer avec
tant de vigueur cette mission
constitutionnelle
toutefois nous pourrons sans doute
engager une réflexion sur la
multiplication des activités qui peut
poser des difficultés de présence en
particulier aux groupes minoritaires ou
conduire à exiger des sénateurs des dons
d'ubiquité qu'ils n'ont pas 124 424
actions de contrôle c'est beaucoup si
l'on souhaite assurer dans la durée une
prise en charge politique matériel et
administratives nous faut donc trouver
un équilibre pour un contrôle moins
dispersé plus efficace plus suivis et
donner à nos travaux le meilleur impact
les travaux transversaux produit par les
commissions et délégations constitue une
voie intéressante dont la session
écoulée a confirmé le succès et la
richesse le contrôle de l'application
des lois est ainsi le prolongement
naturel de la fonction législative
il en constitue très souvent le
préalable nécessaire comme l'illustrent
l'action de la commission pour le
contrôle de l'application des lois aux
côtés des commissions permanentes
nous pouvons également nous féliciter du
bilan de notre
délégation à l'outre-mer qui a dès sa
première année engager les travaux en
prise directe avec les préoccupations de
nos concitoyens ultramarins
la grande qualité du rapport commun de
cette délégation et de la commission des
affaires économiques sur l'impact
économique de la défiscalisation vient
de le confirmer
chers collègues tout au long de la
session 2012 2013
le sénat a pleinement assurer son rôle
de représentant des collectivités
territoriales a été je le crois à
l'écouté des élus locaux nous avons en
effet commencé la session avec des états
généraux de la démocratie territoriale
grâce auquel nous avons renoué le fil du
dialogue entre l'état et les acteurs
locaux et nous avons presque achevé la
session avec l'examen du premier volet
de la réforme territoriale présentée par
le gouvernement dans ce débat même si
pour beaucoup commencer par le voulait
concernant les métropoles pouvait nuire
à la cohérence recherché le sénat a su
faire entendre sa voix des choix
courageux ont été faits vers une plus
grande lisibilité et une plus grande
efficacité pour nos territoires
cela a été possible grâce au climat de
concertation et au travail de notre
commission des lois ce résultat montre
que le pluralisme qui suscitent parfois
la perplexité des commentateurs
politiques nous oblige à faire preuve
d'ouverture et de pragmatisme pour
trouver ensemble les solutions les plus
conformes à l'intérêt général
à l'heure où notre pays traverse la
crise que vous connaissez le sénat
consacré de nombreuses heures à l'examen
de textes qui répondait aux premières
préoccupations des français la lutte
contre le chômage et la relance de la
croissance des projets de loi créant les
emplois d'avenir et des contrats de
génération mais aussi la loi de
sécurisation de l'emploi ou encore la
création de la banque publique
d'investissement en sont l'illustration
au delà de l'économie et de l'emploi
toutes les priorités des français ont
été au coeur de notre ordre du jour
je pense naturellement au logement mais
aussi aux textes portant sur l'éducation
la section 2002 la session 2012 2013
nous a également rappelé que les débats
qui agitent la société ne met jamais
longtemps à passer le seuil du parlement
comme ce fut souvent le cas au cours de
son histoire le sénat était d'acteurs
convaincu de la lutte pour l'égalité des
droits
pour preuve le projet de loi ouvrant le
mariage et l'adoption aux couples de
même sexe détient un record pour cette
session cinquante et une heure de débat
en séance publique et presque autant
pour les travaux des commissions chers
collègues au cours de cette session
particulièrement chargé le sénat a
confirmé sa mobilisation et son
expertise sur les sujets internationaux
notre assemblée s'est littéralement
déployé vers l'étranger c'est a su que
j'ai eu l'honneur de conduire
l'importante délégation du sénat
invitées à commémorer le 50e
anniversaire du traité de l'elysée le 22
janvier dernier à berlin en matière
européenne de l'accord intervenu en
avril sur la création d'une conférence
interparlementaire associant le
parlement européen et les parlements
nationaux pour débattre des politiques
budgétaires est une avancée importante
qui doit renforcer la légitimité
démocratique de l'union économique et
monétaire
cet accord peut être considéré comme un
succès pour le sénat carrier largement
inspiré des positions que nous avons
défendues lors de la négociation du
traité sur la stabilité la coordination
et la gouvernance en europe
la première réunion de cette nouvelle
conférence aura lieu dès l'automne
prochain en lituanie
la session aura enfin été marquée par
les débats sur la situation au mali
l'intervention de nos forces armées dans
ce pays a fait l'objet d'un premier
débat dans les jours qui ont suivi le
déclenchement de l'opération serval puis
d'une autorisation de sa prolongation
conformément à l'article 35 alinéa 3 de
la constitution la qualité des débats à
cette occasion nourri par l'excellent
travail de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées
a été saluée par l'ensemble des
observateurs notre mission de
représentation ne faudrait être
accomplie sans un lien étroit avec les
citoyens et les élus locaux
plusieurs initiatives ont contribué au
cours des derniers mois rendre le sénat
plus ouvert et plus accessible à nos
concitoyens en témoigne la présence
renforcée du sénat sur les réseaux
sociaux où des centaines de milliers
d'internautes suivent aujourd'hui notre
actualité en ce qui concerne
l'audiovisuel un contrat d'objectifs et
de moyens était conclu le 12 décembre
dernier avec la chaîne public sénat
parmi les dix huit objectifs assignés à
la chaîne je retiendrai notamment celui
consistant à améliorer
l'enracinement sénatoriale de la grille
dans le strict respect du pluralisme
politique
toujours dans le domaine audiovisuel un
accord a été conclu avec france
télévisions pour restaurer un
rendez-vous fixe sur france 3 le jeudi à
15 heures ainsi les téléspectateurs
peuvent suivre en direct les questions
d'actualité et les questions cribles
même s'il faut bien le reconnaître nous
avons à nous interroger pour assurer
plus de présence dans ces moments là
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
pour finir j'aimerais évoquer des
questions qui touchent à l'avenir de
notre assemblée
la crise que traverse notre pays est
certes une crise économique mais nous
connaissons aussi une crise politique et
si j'ose jeu si j'ose le dire une crise
morale
les citoyens regarde avec beaucoup de
perplexité leurs institutions
parfois même avec des finances pour
répondre à leurs interrogations
le parlement doit se réformer le premier
axe de réforme c'est celui de la
représentativité
nous devons être le fidèle reflet de la
diversité des citoyens le disait
deuxième axe c'est celui de la gestion
budgétaire
nous devons êtres y réfléchir et pro
châble dans l'utilisation que nous
faisons de notre dotation de
fonctionnement pour respecter cette
exigence
j'ai souhaité améliorer notre dispose
tif de contrôle interne en faisant appel
à l'expertisé de la cour des comptes
la convention qui lui permettra de
certifier directement nos comptes sera
prochainement examiné par notre bureau
le troisième axe c'est celui de la
déontologie le sénat jouer en la matière
un rôle précurseur puisque nous avons
publié dès l'été 2012 sur notre site
internet
les déclarations d'activité et d'intérêt
de tous les sénateurs
nous devons donc encore approfondir
cette réflexion c'est l'un des sujets
qui nous occupera lors de cette session
extraordinaire avec l'examen des textes
relatifs à la transparence de la vie
publique
mes chers collègues après ce bilan de la
session 2012 2013
mes derniers mots avant que nous ne
reprenons le cours normal de nos travaux
seront des mots de gratitude et de
reconnaissance
ma reconnaissance s'adresse en premier
lieu à chacun d'entre vous pour
l'immense travail accompli au service de
nos concitoyens je sais que l'intensité
de nos travaux a exigé une mobilisation
de tous les instants
soyez en remerciés vous permettrait
d'avoir une pensée particulière pour les
vice présidents du sénat qui ont passé
ici de nombreuses heures de jour comme
de nuit ici au plateau madame la
présidente
messieurs les présidents merci pour
votre vigilance constante pour notre
patience et pour votre sens de l'écouté
qualité grâce auquel nos travaux se sont
déroulés cette année encore dans la
sérénité et dans le respect mutuel
je tiens également à adresser des
remerciements particuliers aux acteurs
institutionnels de notre assemblée qui
ont la lourde tâche de faire vivre le
pluralisme sénatoriales au quotidien et
de garantir la libre expression de
chacun des présidents des groupes
politiques les présidents des conditions
les membres du bureau et de la
conférence des présidents
je souhaite enfin remercier ceux qui ont
travaillé auprès de nous toute l'année
et dont la contribution invisible
le pour le public est pourtant
indispensable au bon déroulement de nos
travaux merci aux fonctionnaires du
sénat qui nous apporte chaque jour leur
appui les maîtres leur grande compétence
au service de cette institution et merci
aux collaborateurs des groupes
politiques
colabor collaborateurs parlementaires
pour leur dévouement et leur
responsabilité pour le rôle essentiel
qu'ils jouent auprès de chaque sénatrice
et de chaque sénateur en votre nom à
tous
je leur exprime notre sincère gratitude
pour le travail qu'ils effectuent à nos
côtés dans des conditions parfois
difficiles
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je souhaite très chaleureusement à
chacun d'entre vous une excellente
session extraordinaire et elle était
réparateur je vous remercie
je vais suspendre la séance pour
quelques minutes la parole est à
monsieur françois zocchetto pour un
rappel au règlement mais monsieur lézard
également pont et bien merci monsieur le
président si chers collègues m'ont
rappelé règlement est fondée sur les
articles 36 et 29 de notre règlement sur
le président du sénat a tiré un bilan
positif du travail du sénat c'est exact
sénat travaille beaucoup et il le fait
dans un esprit d'ouverture que nous
saluons tous la question est de savoir
si le travail dans de bonnes conditions
l'article 29 de la constitution dispose
que le parlement ait réuni en session
extraordinaire sur un ordre du jour
déterminé en réalité mes chers collègues
ce ne sont plus des sessions
extraordinaires mais des cessions ou une
accumulation de textes de tous ordres
pour examen en toute hâte avec un ordre
du jour à géométrie variable des lettres
modificative qui partent dès que la la
session extraordinaire est annoncée dans
des conditions qui nous paraissent peu
acceptable ordre du jour où l'on
retrouve trop de texte a examiné en
procédure accélérée
l'accumulation de textes importants en
particulier au niveau de la commission
des lois un rythme déraisonnable ne
permet plus en tout cas c'est ce que
nous pensons nous un travail de qualité
ce rythme devenant peu soutenable je les
dis en particulier pour les groupes dits
minoritaires
s'il s'agit de montrer à l'opinion
publique que le gouvernement et sa
majorité travaille cela de cette manière
là ne me paraît pas concourir à la
réalisation d'un bon travail législatif
de qualité en tout cas ce que nous
dénoncions ici nombreux sous la
précédente majorité
nous le dénonçons de la même manière
aujourd'hui le sénat est souvent et
justement décrit comme une chambre de
réflexion permettant par son travail
d'améliorer la qualité des textes
législatifs à continuer ainsi si le
gouvernement continue ainsi c'est la
justification même du bicamérisme qui
sera touchée rappels au règlement
la parole est un monsieur françois
zocchetto crée également en invoquant
également l'article 36 et l'article 29
du règlement pour faire ce rappel
monsieur le président du sénat a en
effet salué le travail du sénat durant
la session écoulée
il est bien légitime que les efforts des
uns et des autres soient saluer mais je
ne suis pas convaincu que cette ardeur
qui a été la nôtre soit compatible avec
notre souhait réaffirmé de lutter contre
la production excessive de normes
s'agissant de la session qui s'ouvre et
dont le qualificatif d' extraordinaire
est en effet de moins en moins mérité
tant ce type de cession devient
récurrente
je voudrais souligner les quatre points
suivants qui reflète les difficultés
rencontrées par le les parlementaires et
par les collaborateurs du sénat pour
travailler dans les conditions qui nous
sont imposés
premièrement nous allons étudier trop de
textes 42 texte d'après mes calculs
devons peut-être évoqué entre le 2
juillet et le 26 juillet ce n'est pas
sérieux de mieux dire que nous devons
nous devrons évacuer 42 texte
deuxièmement chacun constatera un
mauvais équilibre de la charge de
travail entre les semaines il ya des
semaines avec des séances de nuit
et puis il y a des semaines pendant
lesquelles nous travaillons en
pointillés ce qu'on reproche
travail en temps partiel dans certains
métiers troisième remarque ce sont les
des zi qui les déséquilibres à
l'intérieur même des semaines de travail
de nombreux textes importants commençant
à être étudié le mercredi soir voire le
jeudi pour se poursuivre jusqu'au samedi
parfois et enfin un quatrième et
dernière remarque je j'évoquerai les
modifications incessantes moi aussi dans
l'ordre du jour venant remettre en cause
le calendrier retenu par la conférence
des présidents
ainsi ces derniers jours nous avons nous
avons reçu de lettre rectificative sans
qu'il y ait de réunion de la conférence
des présidents
vous avez compris monsieur le président
qu'il n'est pas possible de continuer à
travailler ainsi
merci monsieur lennon a été donnée de ce
rappel au règlement l'ordre du jour
appelle le débat sur la réforme de la
politique agricole commune
la parole d'un monsieur stéphane le foll
ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
le président mesdames messieurs dont je
vais vous faire une présentation de
l'accord qui a été passé la semaine
dernière entre le parlement le conseil
des ministres de l'agriculture est aussi
la commission sur la réforme de la
politique agricole commune
je suis très satisfait que le sénat est
organisé ce débat car j'ai pu constater
retour de luxembourg près quelques jours
et quelques nuits de négociations que
sur une question pourtant essentielle
touche à l'agriculture à 500 mille
exploitants après d'un avion doivent
être femme qui travaille dans le domaine
de l'agriculture et autour de
l'agriculture les enjeux de cette
réforme ne soit pas aussi intéressés ou
intéressant pour nombre de nos médias et
donc il revient au sénat d'ouvrir un
débat sur cette réforme
moi je voudrais dire d'abord les choses
suivantes
la première chose c'est que cette
réforme était le fruit d'une réflexion
qui avait été engagé en 2003 à nu sont
vos réflexions qui consistait à mettre
en place une réforme de la politique
agricole commune avec ce qu'on appelle
des aides à l'hectare des couples et
c'était ça l'objectif
dès 2003 le choix a été fait de
considérer que l'aide qu'on devait
apporter aux agriculteurs devaient être
directement liées ou surface et
indépendants des productions qui ne
pouvait choisir le choix a été fait avec
une ligne d'une stratégie qui consistait
à dire ce n'est pas à l'action publique
et au budget européen d'orienter les
choix des productions des exploitants
agricoles
d'où le découplage avec un risque et on
l'a constaté
dans les mois qui viennent de se passer
les années qui viennent se passer c'est
que lorsque le prix en particulier des
céréales est assez élevé le choix des
agriculteurs
lorsque c'est possible c'est d'arrêter
l'exploitation et l'élevage pour faire
des céréales ont été dans cette logique
là et c'est face à cette logique là qui
consistait au fond derrière à faire le
choix d'une spécialisation des terres
agricoles à l'échelle européenne qu'il a
fallu engager une négociation pour
modifier le cours de la construction de
la politique agricole commune au profit
d'un équilibre nouveau à trouver entre
l'élevage et l'ensemble des productions
à l'échelle européenne
sachant que la france je le dis c'est un
concentré de l'agriculture européenne
elle est à vis culture méditerranéenne
elle est agricultrice de moyenne
montagne elle est agriculture de
montagne elle est intensive est les
productions de céréales lé production
laitière lé polyculture élevage
c'est une photo concentré de ce qui
existe à l'ensemble de l'europe à
l'échelle de l'europe la france
concentre l'ensemble des agricultures
européennes dans leur diversité
donc c'était ça le débat l'objet du
débat comment à partir de là travailler
la proposition qui était sur la table la
part de la commission et quand je suis
arrivé il n'y avait pas beaucoup de
débats sur la question de la réforme de
la politique agricole commune j'ai eu
cette expression j'ai trouvé le débat en
jachère c'est à dire qu'il y avait rien
d'engagé véritablement si ce n'est une
proposition de la commission qui partait
de deux principes fondamentaux la
convergence des aides
c'est à dire le fait qu'on allait aller
vers une aide à l'hectare de base la
même normalement à l'échelle européenne
et quelles que soient les exploitations
c'était ça la logique de la convergence
ce qui faisait que pour des pays comme
la france nous allions sortir de ce
qu'on appelle pour les spécialistes les
dpu
c'est à dire des aides différencier à
l'hectare selon les régions selon les
orientations techniques d exploitation
et avec comme principe pour cette
convergence de fer que partie des aides
en particulier la polyculture élevage au
lait qui connaissent aujourd'hui les dpu
les plus élevés servent à rééquilibrer
les aides en destination des éleveurs du
grand massif central et des zones
méditerranéennes convergence c'est
l'objectif de ramener l'ensemble des
aides qui sont différentes aujourd'hui
au même niveau quelles que soient les
hectares et quelles que soient les
exploitations premiers éléments
donc le débat sur la convergence est
extrêmement importante deuxième débat il
portait sur le verdissement de la
politique agricole commune
c'est à dire l'idée que dans le premier
pilier et pas seulement dans le 2e
pilier
on est des choix stratégiques qui fasse
que l'agriculture européenne s'engage
sur la voie de la durabilité trois
critères avaient été fixés le critère
des prairies permanentes
le critère de la rotation de
diversification des cultures et les
critères des surfaces d'intérêt
écologique sur ces trois critères la
position de la france a été clair
c'était de soutenir l'objectif de
verdissement de la politique agricole
commune
et si la france n'avait pas pesé pour
maintenir les propositions de la
commission
il n'y aurait pas aujourd'hui de
verdissement de cette politique à
l'échelle où il est aujourd'hui
et je le dis d'autant plus que ce soit
c'est aussi le choix qui consiste à dire
que la question de l'environnement ne
peut pas être laissée au simple arbitre
des différents états sauf à conduire à
des divergences en termes de concurrence
entre les états ceux qui ont faut plus
peuvent être pénalisés que ceux qui en
fou - et que c'était si nous n'avions
pas trouvé un accord sur la question du
verdissement le risque d'avoir en europe
le choix favoriser pour les états qui
ferait le moins en termes
d'environnement
donc l'objectif est
éclair convergence verdissement et
régulation j'ai eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer sur ce sujet au cours de
cette négociation nous avons fait bouger
les choses de manière significative nous
sommes revenus par exemple sur ce qui
avait été décidé sur la fin des fameux
droits de plantation viticulture ça
s'est fait dans le cadre de cette
négociation et l'accord est
définitivement intégré à l'accord qui a
été signé la semaine dernière
nous sommes aussi revenu sur le choix
qui avait été fait de la fin des quotas
sucriers dès 2015 nous avons aussi
plaidé pour la reconnaissance ce qui
avait été le cas dès le départ des
interprofessions ses galères la capacité
qu'on a à organiser les filières et ça
c'est dans la réforme de la politique
agricole commune
autant de choix qui sur la question de
la convergence la question
divertissement sur la question de la
régulation reviennent sur des positions
qu'ils avaient pu être prises dans les
années précédentes et réoriente cette
construction de la politique agricole
commune
j'ajoute un point majeur par rapport à
la convergence c'est le choix que qu'a
défendue et que je défends du du fameux
couplage des aides je le disais tout à
l'heure en 2003 le choix avait été celui
du découplage des aides c'est à dire le
fait qu'on donne des aides à l'hectare
sans tenir compte de ce que produisait
les agriculteurs c'était un risque
majeur pour l'élevage
car l'élevage a cette particularité
d'avoir une rentabilité du capital
investi et une productivité du travail
plus faible que dans les autres
exploitations et en particulier les
céréales et si vous ne compense et pas
de manière spécifique
cette faiblesse de la rentabilité du
capital et de la productivité du travail
et lien vous avez ce qui s'est passé des
exploitants des agriculteurs qui
arrêtent élevage pour faire des céréales
d'où la nécessité du couplage des aides
et de le maintenir et d'essayer
d'augmenter la proposition qui avait été
faite par la commission à 10%
nous sommes passés à 12 % au mois de
mars et nous avons terminé à 13 % + 2 %
pour les protéines végétales choix que
nous avions fait pour pouvoir assurer
aussi
une autonomie fourragère à l'europe et
en particuliers aussi à la france donc
dans ce débat majeur sur cette réforme
de la politique agricole commune
l'objectif que j'ai poursuivi dans la
négociation c'est d'assurer la diversité
des agricultures à l'échelle française à
l'échelle européenne c'est de revenir
sur les choix du découplage total pour
favoriser le couplage des aides avec
comme objectif d'élevage c'est aussi
d'assurer le verdissement de cette
politique agricole commune parce que je
veux qu'à l'échelle de l'europe
tout le monde soit sur un pied d'égalité
sur cet engagement majeur de la
durabilité de l'agriculture européenne
et puis sur la régulation nous avons
veillé à avoir et à maintenir des outils
de régulation parce que nous avons
besoin de cette régulation pour gérer
les marchés agricoles je pense en
particulier à l'engagement qui a été
pris sous la pression de la france
d'avoir une réunion à haut niveau sur la
question des quotas laitiers
c'est à dire l'après quotas laitiers qui
sans cette ce débat sur la réforme
n'auraient pas été obtenues
j'ajouterai quelques points précis pour
la première fois les grecs seront
reconnus à l'échelle européenne
jusqu'ici il était reconnu de manière
dérogatoire et pour moi c'est un enjeu
majeur qui allie à la fois la dimension
économique nécessaire pour assurer la
compétitivité de notre agriculture et en
même temps la nécessité de garder des
chefs d'exploitation c'est-à-dire des
agriculteurs et des paysans pour notre
agriculture dans l'avenir c'est la
première fois je l'avais dit en
plaisantant même jacques chirac n'avait
pas obtenu la reconnaissance de la
transparence des grecs c'est fait et ça
c'est très important
c'est aussi ce que nous avons obtenu sur
l'ensemble des mae
c'est à dire des possibilités que nous
avons de mener des politiques sur le 2e
pilier
avec un élément là encore à destination
des vagues qui a consisté à déplafonner
les aides compensatrices d'handicap de
passer d'un plafond de 300 euros
l'hectare un plafond à 450 euros
l'hectare
ce qui est un signe aussi d'envoyer à
l'élevage et en particulier l'élevage
dans les zones à handicaps naturels
voilà la stratégie
il a été de d'équilibré de rééquilibrer
ce qu'était la politique agricole
commune aujourd'hui dans le sens de
trouver à l'élevage et de donner surtout
l'élevage les moyens de pérenniser cette
activité essentielle pour l'aménagement
de l'occupation du territoire
à un moment où vous le savez ici au
sénat l'élevage connaît des difficultés
c'est la capacité que nous avons eues a
fixé un objectif en terme
environnemental à l'ensemble de l'europe
pour intégrer cette dimension et faire
de l'agriculture européenne
une agriculture durable c'est aussi
d'être revenu d'être venu sur ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur le couplage
des aides
là encore pour changer la logique de la
pac c'est enfin la question de la
régulation des marchés très importants
pour permettre à l'europe de mieux
lutter contre la volatilité extrêmement
importante des prix enfin et je
terminerai par ce point c'est dans le
cadre de cette réforme de la politique
agricole que pour la première fois on a
instauré aussi une politique européenne
obligatoire pour l'installation des
jeunes qui fait d'ailleurs écho au choix
qui ont été faits par le président de la
république partager maintenant à
l'échelle européenne sur la politique à
destination de la jeunesse est bien dans
cette réforme de la politique agricole
commune
là aussi il ya eu un geste significatif
qui a été fait puisque nous pourrons à
la fois sur le premier pilier de la pac
et sur le 2e pilier avoir des fonds
destinés à l'installation des jeunes
installés des jeunes aujourd'hui c'est
avoir confiance dans l'avenir de
l'agriculture
je crois qu'ici au cdh à tous sur tous
les bancs nous partageons cette belle
ambition
la france est un grand pays
ricol la france reste un grand pays
agricole
la france sera demain à grands pays
agricoles merci monsieur le ministre
dans la suite du débat la parole et à
monsieur joël labbé pour le groupe
écologie
monsieur le président messieurs le
président raul qui avait souhaité ce
débat monsieur le ministre on a compris
monsieur le ministre que les
négociations ont été longues et rudes et
que vous êtes arrivé à une certaine
forme de compromis qui pour nous ne nous
satisfait qu'à moitié étant donné nos
attentes nous partons de loin évidemment
quelques chiffres méritent d'être
rappelées 20 % des exploitations acteurs
actuellement s'accapare 80 % des aides
directes et en france les 160 plus
grandes exploitations touche 123
millions d'euros annuels soit autant que
les 100000 plus petit monsieur le
ministre nous tenons d'abord à saluer le
rôle que vous avez pu jouer en plate en
plaçant la france à la tête des pays
souhaitant régulation en cette période
où la logique libérale rejoint la
logique de repli national dans le
domaine agricole comme dans trop de
domaines
au moment où il est temps de
véritablement faire l'europe
votre ténacité à défendre le principe
d'une pac un tant soit peu régulatrice
ifs
il faut avoir à l'esprit que nombre
d'états ne sont pas sur ses positions
la possibilité d'un couplage des aides
jusqu'à 15% le taux porté à 13 % comme
vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure par
rapport à la proposition initiale de 10
% et par ailleurs les 2% supplémentaires
obtenus pour la production de protéines
végétales
ce sont des avancées mais également la
majoration des aides directes sur les
premiers hectares de toutes les
exploitations
cette mesure est de nature à favoriser
les exploitations qui emploie le volet
emploi est temps pour nous essentiel il
a été et continue d'ailleurs d'être bien
mise à mal par le modèle productiviste
et enfin une majoration obligatoire des
aides pour les jeunes agriculteurs
au sein du premier pilier
ce soutien nouveau complétera les
soutiens existants c'est une avancée
aussi intéressante
il est cependant dommage que ces aides
ne soit pas conditionnée à des projets
d'installation répondant à des objectifs
de création d'emplois en même temps que
la protection de l'environnement et de
bonne gestion des ressources naturelles
la jeune qui s'installe on cette
occasion de ne pas s'enferrer dans ce
système qui a broyé une partie de la
génération qui les a précédés et nombre
d'entre eux soit entré dans une autre
forme d'agriculture
s'il y a un certain nombre de sujets de
satisfaction
on reste bien loin des propositions
initiales qui voulait une pac plus verte
une pac plus juste une pac plus jeunes
tout d'abord le tournant vers une pac
plus verte n'est pas véritablement
abouti quelques mesures de verdissement
qui ont pu subsister par rapport à
l'initial sont laissés à l'acte raciste
à l'appréciation des états membres qui
pour la plupart les rendront le moins
contraignante possible quant à la
rotation obligatoire des cultures que
proposait le groupe des verts au
parlement européen
cette mesure a été écartée d'emblée elle
n'a pas été étudiée pourtant tout en
favorisant le rétablissement de notre
balance commerciale
elle allait dans le sens d'une réduction
de notre dépendance vis-à-vis des
importations de soja en provenance
d'amérique du sud d'une amélioration de
la qualité des sols est une réduction de
l'utilisation des intrants
cela aurait été une belle victoire un
signe fort pour le développement d'un
modèle agricole plus durable à l'heure
où l'agroécologie fait beaucoup parler
d'elle et on en est heureux
cette seule mesure conclat concrètes
auraient permis d'en favoriser l'essor
au contraire on se rend compte que c'est
encore le lobby de l'agro industrie qui
a pesé la monoculture va pouvoir
continuer à se développer sur 75 % de la
surface des exploitations qui le
souhaitent
enfin cette nouvelle pac mais pas aussi
juste qu'on aurait pu l'espérer
la convergence des raids des aides ne
permettra pas un réel
on se faire au pays au profit de
l'élevage notamment les gros céréaliers
reste toujours les grands gagnants même
les sommes qu'ils touchent sont
d'ailleurs préservée même si elles
pourront être réduites mais pas au delà
de 30 % d'ici à 2020 si c'est une
avancée on ne peut s'en satisfaire
quant au plafonnement des aides le
parlement européen avait fixé à un
niveau déjà bien élevé de 300000 euros
et aujourd'hui plus rien ne subsiste
dans l'accord cette mesure a simplement
disparu pourtant elles ne figuraient que
très à la marge le modèle agro
industriel intensif puisqu'elle ne
concernait que 35 mille exploitations
agricoles sur les 13 millions de ferme
européenne les états membres ne sont
tout simplement plus tenues de
l'appliquer
cette nouvelle n'est pas vraiment
rassurante sans plafonnement des aides
c'est le règne de la concurrence interne
qui reste favorisés et les plus gros
pour racheter leurs voisins faillite et
cela avec le soutien de l'argent des
contribuables cet accord montre surtout
que nous nous éloignons de plus en plus
de l'idéal communautaire de solidarité
et entre paysans européens ce qui est
idéal qui était le fondement même de la
politique agricole communautaire
cependant la partie n'est pas totalement
joué puisque des marges de manoeuvre est
maintenant plus importante au niveau des
états donc monsieur le ministre la
future loi d'avenir agricole sera pour
nous une étape cruciale devons nous
devons nous s'ouvre une période
intéressante
il faut qu ici le montrions l'exemple un
favorisant la recherche et son
application par des modes de production
plus respectueux de l'environnement
créateurs d'emplois durables de
développement des zones rurales
va-t-on permettre que la majorité des
paysans deviennent de simples sous
traitant sans droits de l'industrie
agroalimentaire et de l'agrochimie ou
bien va-t-on enfin créer les conditions
pour que les agriculteurs soient les
moteurs d'une économie relocalisée
l'enjeu est là monsieur le ministre nous
comptons sur vous et monsieur le
ministre dans la mesure où vous nous
engager vers ses orientations
nous serons avec vous je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur jean paul
emorine pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'organisation de ce débat sur la
politique agricole commune présente
beaucoup d'intérêt même si le délai est
très court après l'aboutissement des
négociations européennes la semaine
dernière et qu'il reste quelques étapes
institutionnelles temps sur le cadre
financier pluriannuel européen 2014-2020
que sur la pac
mon collègue gérard césar rappellera
dans quelques instants les orientations
du groupe de travail sur la pac auquel
appartenait et qui a récemment adopté à
l'unanimité une proposition de
résolution sur la politique agricole
commune
pour ma part j'ai intervient au nom du
groupe ump et vous prie de bien vouloir
excuser l'absence de notre collègue jean
bizet très impliqué également sur ce 6è
mais qui participent à la session
annuelle de l'eau et c'est eux et qui
n'a pu rejoint notre mais cycle dans les
temps je souhaite d'abord rappelé
combien la pac représente un succès des
politiques et européennes et qu'il
convient de la préserver c'est un succès
non tant pas parce qu'elle est d'un des
principaux postes de dépense du budget
européen mais parce que c'est une
politique commune en place depuis 1962
et qui depuis lors a connu plusieurs
réformes et a toujours su s'adapter aux
nécessités économiques
allard souffle parfois un vent de
scepticisme sur l'avenir de l'union
européenne il me semble indispensable de
mettre en valeur ce qui répond aux
attentes de nos concitoyens
cette pac en constante adaptation
nous en avons encore la preuve avec la
pause en précédentes la présente réforme
qui en août s'inscrit dans un cadre
budgétaire contraint que je regrette
personnellement c'est pourquoi nous
comprenons parfaitement l'attitude de
nos collègues eurodéputés du ppe qui se
sont approprié les prérogatives de leur
donne au traité de lisbonne en matière
de co décision et qu'ils ont souhaité
un budget européen plus autonome plus
flexible est révisable en cours de
période
les négociations sur la réforme de la
politique agricole commune ont donc
cheminée en parallèle de celle sur le
cadre financier pluriannuel
il n'en demeure pas moins qu'il est fort
peu probable que la nouvelle pac entre
en vigueur au 1er janvier 2014 ce sera
plutôt vers le 1er janvier 2015
il est dès lors plus important que nos
agriculteurs puissent anticiper les
montants en jeu
et leurs modalités d'affectation de
façon à pouvoir programmer leurs
investissements et la gestion de leur
exploitation
ainsi si nous pouvons comprendre qu'en
période de crise chacun doit faire un
effort on en constant pas moins que
contrairement à ce que dit le
gouvernement
le gouverneur gray culture sur la
fortement mise à contribution dans le
nouveau cadre financier pluriannuel
moins de 59 50 milliards globalement
soit moins d'un milliard par an pour la
france
à ce titre monsieur le ministre a très
habilement présenter le résultat des
négociations en annonçant un milliard de
plus sur le 2e pilier
mais en se gardant de préciser que cette
épouse 7 ans et non annuellement en août
ces crédits seront offerts affecté par
l'aco magri lors d'un vote en juillet ou
en septembre puis en séance plénière
nous pouvons dire que cette nouvelle pac
et dans ses principes plus respectueuse
de l'environnement grâce à la
convergence des aides et au verdissement
il n'en reste pas moins des
interrogations sur la mise en oeuvre
nationale de ces dispositifs qui dans
cette pac renouvelé sur important par
exemple en france
des références historiques vont
disparaît nous aimerions savoir monsieur
le ministre comment va fonctionner le
nouveau système d'attribution des droits
à paiement de base et comment vous allez
garantir qu'il n'y ait pas un effort
trop brutale la première année il est
nécessaire d'encadrer la convergence
interne pour éviter les trop grandes
disparités
tout en ayant pour objectif la
convergence définitive peut-être à
l'horizon 2020 toujours le niveau de la
convergence
les états auront la possibilité
d'affecter une part de leurs enveloppes
nationales afin d'accorder un paiement
supplémentaire aux 50 premiers hectares
mais il faut qu'elle remplisse son
objectif de compenser la diversité des
exploitations c'est pourquoi mais vous
l'avez confirmé le ministre il est
obligatoire que les gays soient prises
en considération
la pac doit en effet être à même de
prendre en compte les difficultés des
zones de montagne et des zones
défavorisées qui préserve nos élevages
et sont en voie de désertification et à
ce titre ce sont bien les états membres
qui peuvent octroyer un paiement
supplémentaire pour les zones soumises à
contraintes naturelles en matière de
verdissement
nous devons aussi tenir compte de la
réalité des situations locales en termes
de délimitation des surfaces d'intérêt
biologique notamment dans la mesure où
les états pourront adopter un système de
pondération en fonction de l'intérêt
écologique pour les prairies pour des
raisons agronomique certains espaces où
plein sont retournés afin de garantir
une meilleure flore ce qui doit être
respecté le ministre c'est la superficie
toujours en herbe de l'exploitation en
août
j'appelle le gouvernement à exercer
toute sa vigilance lors de l'élaboration
par la commission de la matrice
d'équivalence des surfaces d'intérêt
écologique
de façon générale il faut être prudents
sur le niveau de chasseurs qui doivent
prendre en compte à l'avenir la
nécessité de nourrir 9 milliards d'êtres
humains à l'horizon 2050
par ailleurs on regarde la situation
plus particulière des biocarburants et
de la révision des normes communautaires
qui leur sont applicables
il me semble que nous devons être aussi
vigilant car le principe de la recherche
en la matière et la progressive montée
en puissance sans rupture rupture claire
entre une première et deuxième
génération
il faudrait donc veiller à préserver la
filière existantes
enfin tant sur le premier pilier
lorsque cela est autorisée que sur le 2e
pilier nous attendons que les
cofinancements nationaux soit à la
hauteur dans un contexte difficile pour
nos finances publiques en particulier
pour les assurances aléas climatiques
le gouvernement doit s'engager à avoir
un cofinancement qui permettent de
prendre en charge 65 % du montant des
primes d'assurance et non peut-être
peine comme vous l'avez signalé au
ministre 50%
ces assurances deviennent en effet
incontournable pour garantir la
pérennité de nos exploitations
toujours dans cette même perspective
j'aimerais savoir monsieur le ministre
si vos services et ceux de bercy mais
c'est valable pour tous les
gouvernements de ce ministre mène une
réflexion sur la possibilité d'une
garantie de réassurance au lieu de
continuer d'intervenir sur le fonds des
calamités agricoles
enfin de ce ministre j'aimerais insister
sur deux pointes et pour l'avenir de
notre agriculture et qui sont
entièrement du ressort national
d'abord nous devons continuer de
soutenir ceux qui marchent en
particulier la politique d'installation
des jeunes permettez moi de le rappeler
20% des chefs d'exploitation ou moins de
40 ans dans notre pays alors que la
moyenne européenne se situe à 6 %
c'est un début de garanties pour
l'avenir de notre agriculture
préservons le à ce titre nous sommes
très sensibles à ce que l'accord sur la
pac rendre obligatoires les directs
majoré aux jeunes agriculteurs et ce
jusqu'à 2 % de l'enveloppé nationale des
paiements directs
d'autre part nous devons veiller à ne
pas alourdir la gestion des
exploitations agricoles par des
décisions administratives qui irait au
delà de celles exigées par la
réglementation européenne
cela retarde le démarrage des
exploitations augmente les coûts de
production et pèse sur leurs compétences
compétitivité j'en veux pour preuve la
louve la lourdeur des autorisations pour
construire des bâtiments d'élevage ou
des dispositions en préparation de
l'épandage quand le commissaire ciolos
se félicite d'une pac qui réduit le rôle
des autorités publiques et de
l'intervention de l'otan
pratique il n'est pas opportun que nous
faisions l' inverse au niveau national
monsieur le ministre pour conclure nous
avons toujours défendu une agriculture d
exploitation est une filière
agroalimentaire compétitive et nous
continuerons de les défendre c'est
d'autant plus vrai en période de crise
économique et de chômage
c'est d'autant plus vrai que
l'agriculture couvre 4 60% de notre
territoire et elle permet d'occuper
notre espace que si les activités de
production et de nourriture de qualité
pour nos concitoyens
la parole est à madame bernadette
bourzai pour le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je me
réjouis que nous ayons ce débat
aujourd'hui dans cet hémicycle quelques
jours seulement après le dernier
trilogue qui s'est conclue par un accord
pour une nouvelle politique agricole
commune à partir de 2014
je m'en réjouis d'autant plus qu'au
lendemain de cet accord
l'accord sur le cadre financier
pluriannuel 2014-2020 lui aussi été
trouvés ce qui permet de penser que les
éléments qui restaient en suspens dans
les négociations de la pac qui ont été
évoqués par notre collègue et maureen
vont pouvoir maintenant être clarifiée
en effet la pac façonnent notre
agriculture depuis cinquante ans cette
politique européenne la plus visible de
l'union est naturellement au coeur de
nos préoccupations pour nos territoires
ruraux et notre assemblée ya consacré un
travail important et dense pour
accompagner nourrir la réflexion sur
cette réforme qui va organiser la pac
pour les sept prochaines années
quelques remarques liminaires car cette
réforme qui pour la première fois se
faisait en codécision avec le parlement
européen
démarrée sous des auspices plutôt
pessimiste
la tendance du gouvernement précédent
était plutôt à la baisse
d'abord sur le budget ensuite baisse des
possibilités d'être couplé abandon
programmé des outils de régulation et
alors que dire de la redistribution et
de la dégressivité des aides qu'ils
étaient des sujets tabous
vous avez monsieur le ministre depuis
votre arrivée au ministère de
l'agriculture mis tout en oeuvre pour
inverser cette tendance et pour aboutir
dans des délais très courts mais cela
était nécessaire à une réforme pour une
pac plus équitable plus verte et plus
régulatrice
autant le dire cette réforme n'était pas
acquise d'avancé et s'engager mal et
vous avez réussi à aboutir et cela grâce
à votre excellente connaissance des
dossiers de la pac des institutions
européennes et de leur fonctionnement et
aussi grâce à la ténacité du président
de la république françois hollande pour
sauvegarder une dotation conséquente
dans le cadre budgétaire 2014 2020
puisque la france bénéficiera de 56
millions
d'euros constants sur la période de sept
ans soit 63 7 milliards d'euros courants
si cette réforme de la pac n'avait pas
vocation à révolutionner le système
agricole européen et j'ai bien entendu
joël labbé qui d'une certaine façon le
regrette mais plutôt à organiser une
transition vers l'agriculture de demain
elle apporte néanmoins des évolutions
majeures qui vont avoir une incidence
significative et durable sur
l'agriculture européenne
j'ai déjà évoqué les moyens pour
l'agriculture française il reste
conséquent
malgré la baisse globale du budget
agricole de 12% qui pour la france sera
limitée à 2% seulement
j'en viens maintenant contenu de cet
accord
vous avez monsieur le ministre soit
choisi d'oeuvrer pour une pac plus juste
dont la priorité qu'une redistribution
en faveur de l'élevage et de l'emploi ce
donc je ne peux que vous féliciter
la priorité donnée à l'élevage en
premier lieu est impérative car nos
éleveurs souffrent vous le savez et
j'ouvre la une parenthèse les travaux de
la mission d'information commune sur la
filière viande du sénat que j'ai
l'honneur de présider et qui va bientôt
rendre ses conclusions montrent encore
plus convaincu de l'absolue nécessité de
donner la priorité à l'élevage toutes
filières confondues
ces dix dernières années de dérégulation
de volatilité des prix et de perte de
compétitivité en mise à mal tout notre
appareil productif avec des conséquences
désastreuses sur la filière des
industries agroalimentaires et sur
l'emploi dont nous avons pu mesurer les
conséquences tout au long de nos
auditions et de nos déplacements
je ne peux donc appuyé avec force votre
détermination pour défendre et soutenir
l'élevage et en cela les mesures qui ont
été introduites sous votre impulsion
dans la réforme de la pac vont dans le
bon sens et vont nous donner les outils
nécessaires
c'est d'abord le maintien d'un taux de
couplage élevé le taux renforcée des
aides couplées est à saluer lui ce qu'il
est
il a été porté à 13 % avec la
possibilité de 2% supplémentaires dédiés
à la production des protéagineux qui
permettra de soutenir le développement
de l'autonomie fourragère protéique des
exploitations d'élevage la convergence
des aides
deuxièmement avec la surprime des
premiers hectares introduite à votre
initiative et accepté par les pays qui
le souhaiteront cette mesure sera
favreau favorable à l'élevage et aux
exploitations intensives en main
d'oeuvre et reconnaîtra également les
actifs chef d'exploitation puisqu'elle
sera appliquée comme vous l'avez
réaffirmé avec le principe de
transparence pour les grecs
je peux vous dire et madame goy chavent
le confirmera que nous avons été
interrogés dans la saône et loire et
dans l'ain sur cette question avec
beaucoup beaucoup d'attention dans le
semble dans le second pilier la
possibilité de poursuivre le plan
bâtiment d'élevage qui est absolument
nécessaire
toujours dans le second pilier le
maintien de la prime à l'herbe et les
mesures agro environnementales dont les
modalités sont à préciser notamment sur
le maintien des prairies permanentes
mais renée nicoux en parlera tout à
l'heure le renforcement de l'indemnité
compensatoire de handicap naturel et
tout particulièrement dans les zones de
montagne avec un relèvement du plafond
des haines des aides en zone de montagne
que vous avez obtenu tout en restant
vigilant sur le zonage des piémonts et
les zones défavorisées intermédiaire je
suis très sensible à cette réorientation
1 serait rééquilibrage qui doit
permettre de relancer les productions et
les industries agroalimentaires qui sont
la première industrie en france
nous défendons une application
progressive de la convergence pro que
nous l'avons dit dans la proposition de
résolution européenne qui vous a été
adressé mais nous sommes convaincus que
l'échéance doit être précisément
programmé en cela le maintien d'une
échéance à 2020 et
satisfaisant pour finir sur les aides
directes aux mots de satisfaction sur
l'appui aux jeunes agriculteurs qui sera
aussi augmentée avec une aide directe
majoré à hauteur de 25% pour 2% de
l'envelope financière là aussi la
question a été largement évoquée
vendredi après midi dans un élevage ovin
autre nouveauté le verdissement pour une
pac plus verte
malgré toutes les tentatives pour la
vider de son sens et de toute ambition
cette réforme réorientera bien le
développement agricole vers plus de
durabilité 30% des aides du premier
pilier via un paiement verts seront
destinés à soutenir des pratiques
agricoles plus respectueuses de
l'environnement et de même 30 % des
soutiens au développement du rural
devons être dirigés vers des mesures de
protection de l'environnement et de
lutte contre le changement climatique
sans double paiement comme certains
l'espéraient
enfin certaines avancées vers plus de
régulation peuvent être soulignés tels
que l'encadrement des droits de
plantation des quotas de sucre le
renforcement des organisations de
producteurs et je dois vous faire part
monsieur le ministre de l'inquiétude des
producteurs laitiers
vous le savez je voudrais citer ici le
rapport qui a été présenté par rené
souchon comité des régions très
récemment sur cette question des quotas
laitiers et qui donne en particulier
des informations précises sur le contenu
du sarm bill américain qui permet de
rétablir une certaine régulation alors
si les états unis le fond je crois que
l'union européenne serait bien inspiré
de revenir à un peu de régulation
je conclurai monsieur le ministre en
disant que certes la réforme de la pac
pour la période 2014 2020 n'est qu'une
étape dans la longue histoire de cette
politique communautaire majeur qui doit
le rester
mais les enjeux d'une agriculture à la
fois productive et durable plus
respectueuse des territoires et de
l'environnement assurant une
rémunération correcte à tous les
agriculteurs et relégitimer aux yeux des
consommateurs
ils sont bien présents nous aurons
monsieur le ministre l'occasion d'en
reparler à propos de la loi d'avenir que
nous soutiendrons avec enthousiasme et
conviction
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur gérard le cam pour le groupe
crc
sur le président ce ministre mes chers
collègues le débat intervient dans le
cadre des négociations de la pac avant
la fin de la présidence irlandaise
l'objectif déboucher sur un consensus
avant cette échéance a été atteint la
semaine dernière
même s'il s'agit d'un consensus mou et
même si en réalité les états et les
institutions européennes achoppent
toujours sur un certain nombre de sujets
à cela s'ajoutent des incertitudes
pesant sur le budget qui ne sera
définitivement acté qu'à la rentrée il
ressort des informations assez vague que
nous avons eues sur le contenu de cette
entente une profonde déception et une
inquiétude certaine quant au devenir de
l'agriculture française et européenne
en effet le résultat des négociations
montre à quel point la volonté politique
de construire une politique agricole
européenne fondée sur des exigences
sociales environnementales et de
solidarité est inexistante
l'austérité l'ultralibéralisme la
dérégulation ont pris le pas ignorons
l'importance stratégique tente
alimentaire qu'économique et social des
activités agricoles les négociations en
cours le montre tant dans le cadre
européen qu'international avec le mandat
donné à l'union européenne pour négocier
l'accord de libre essence europe etats
unis
ce ministre nous sommes convaincus qu'un
débat sur la pac ne peut faire
l'économie de cette question le groupe
crc avait déposé un amendement en
commission des affaires économiques lors
de l'examen de la proposition de
résolution européenne relative au mandat
de négociation nous avions demandé que
les activités agricoles soit soustraite
du mandat de négociation afin de
préserver notre modèle agricole européen
la commission des affaires économiques a
considéré que nos craintes n'étaient pas
justifiées et qui est un tel accord
devait absolument inclure l'agriculture
nous persistons à dire que la fin des
barrières tarifaires et non tarifaires
entre l'union européenne et les
etats-unis représentent un danger pour
les activités agricoles et notamment
pour l'élevage aujourd'hui les syndicats
agricoles dénoncent unanimement un tel
accord qui s'inquiète notamment des
exportations de viande américaine
même la fnsea y voit un accord contraire
à l'agroécologie je les cite
quant au président de la fmb ils
dénoncent le risque pour les éleveurs
français de déstabilisation
d'exploitation déjà extrêmement fragile
pour la filière une baisse accrue
d'activité et enfin pour les
consommateurs la perte des garanties sur
la qualité et sanitaires et la
traçabilité
c'est dans ce contexte sous les
pressions libéral des pays du nord que
l'union européenne traite les
productions agricoles comme de simples
marchandises à bruxelles
de nombreuses voix se sont exprimées
pour s'inquiéter des effets de la
libéralisation des marchés agricoles
alors que les agriculteurs sont
violemment exposé à la spéculation sur
les marchés mondiaux et aux fluctuations
des prix des matières premières cette
même europe supprime les outils de
régulation
certains pays dont le nôtre et cède
encore de maintenir des garde-fous et
parfois quand tout le monde se mobilise
on arrive à retarder la libéralisation
et la mise à mal de pans entiers de
notre agriculture et de notre patrimoine
c'est le cas pour le nouveau régime des
droits de plantation de vignes qui
permettra jusqu'en 2030 gérer les
plantations pour toutes les catégories
de vins avec une limite maximale de
croissance annuel des surfaces plantées
fixé à 1% les états membres ayant la
possibilité de prévoir un seuil de
sauvegarde plus bas au niveau régional
ou national
il est essentiel de préserver le secteur
vinicole qui constitue une véritable
richesse pour notre pays et au delà des
droits de plantation
un autre combat doit être mené contre la
libéralisation des contraintes nos
logiques et contre le projet d'installer
une production de vin de masse sans
identification géographique si nous
saluons le courage des négociateurs et
notre âme en notamment votre pugnacité
monsieur le ministre
dans ces négociations tendues face à
d'autres projets encore plus libéraux
nous ne sommes hélas pas satisfait par
la réforme qui se dégage la nouvelle pac
tourner le dos à la régulation qui est
un enjeu majeur de l'agriculture il nous
semble important de maintenir les outils
de régulation de l'offre
nous condamnons par exemple la fin des
quotas laitiers en 2015 et des quotas
sucriers en 2018
ensuite si nous saluons la convergence
interne des niveaux de paiements directs
et l'abandon des références historiques
nous constatons que le plafonnement des
sommes perçues au delà de 300 mille
euros qui cristallise l'opposition du
royaume uni et de l'allemagne est trop
élevé il en est il est en plus optionnel
comme une bonne partie du dispositif
le rendez-vous en 2019 pour que les
agriculteurs reçoivent en paiements
directs
60 % de la moyenne nationale et que les
mieux dotées ne perdent pas plus de 30%
tout cela relativise l'équité et la
solidarité qui devrait prévaloir dans le
cas d'une véritable politique agricole
commune de plus pouvez nous donner des
précisions sur ce que va représenter la
dégressivité au delà de cent cinquante
mille euros par exploitation dont 5% qui
devraient être versés par les
agriculteurs les plus dotés au 2e pilier
de la pac
l'instauration d'une prime aux 50
premiers hectares est très important
mais là encore tout dépend du montant de
l'aide
pouvez vous nous confirmer le nombre
d'hectares concernés at on des
simulations ensuite nous saluons le
combat français qui a abouti à ce que
les jeunes jusqu'à 40 ans bénéficient
d'une aide supplémentaire jusqu'à 2 % de
l'enveloppé nationale des aides directes
les jeunes agriculteurs rencontrent de
véritables difficultés pour s'installer
il y a un problème général et persistant
de la pression sur les terres et cela
est encore plus vrai en ce qui concerne
l'agriculture biologique
peut-être avez-vous prévu de répondre à
cet enjeu dans le cas de la loi devenir
agricole enfin nous nous réjouissons des
avancées obtenues en ce qui concerne le
couplage des aides qui est fondamental
pour l'élevage en france
l'augmentation du taux de couplage à 13%
+2 % sur les protéines végétales est une
bonne nouvelle
pensez vous que cette possibilité est
combiné à la diversification de culture
pour les exploitations de plus de 10
hectares et 3 pour les plus de 30
la principale pouvant couvrir 75% des
terres disponibles seront suffisants
pour gagner en indépendance en protéines
y aura-t-il une obligation du volet
protéines dans la rotation
enfin je voudrais conclure en insistant
particulièrement sur l'élevage ce sont
des milliers d'emplois qui risquent de
disparaître dans ce secteur et dans le
secteur agroalimentaire le cas des
abattoirs gad dans le finistère l'élu ce
tristement que d'abord il est urgent de
faire cesser le dumping social en europe
le sénateur eric bocquet s'est emparé de
cette question qui a donné lieu à un
rapport d'information
le travailleurs détachés un salarié low
cost ils sont décrites les raisons
principales de l'explosion de la fraude
au détachement
depuis 2004 le secteur agricole a connu
une plus forte augmentation +
3 % du nombre de salariés détachés avant
le bâtiment où l'hôtellerie dans ma
région les éleveurs de porcs ont chiffré
la perte annuelle pour la seule filière
porcine française du fait des
distorsions de concurrence sur le dos
des travailleurs à 125 millions d'euros
il dénonce également les problèmes
d'étiquetage et nous ne manquerons pas
de revenir sur cette question dans la
loi consommation
ils demandent également une
simplification administrative concernant
les procédures appliquées aux
installations classées d'élevage
que comptez-vous faire dans ce domaine
monsieur le ministre il est également
important d'arrêter la végétalisation de
l'agriculture qui a de lourdes
conséquences en termes d'emploi pour
conclure les négociations sur la pac
confirme la volonté de persister dans
une ligne de déréglementation et de
libéralisation de l'agriculture ce que
nous combattons
nous sommes très inquiets pour l'avenir
de notre agriculture et cela d'autant
plus que d'autres négociations
cette fois sous la tutelle du ministère
du commerce extérieur sont en cours et
risques créés à moyen terme de remettre
en cause les quelques avancées que vous
avez gagné monsieur le ministre la loi
d'avenir agricole parviendra-t-elle à
apporter encore un peu de justice dans
ce système nous le souhaitons vivement
monsieur le ministre nous y mettrons
toute notre énergie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur jean jacques lasserre pour le
groupe
udi uc
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
il est entendu ce débat est fondamental
est très important même si on peut
regretter qu'il arrive un peu tard sein
de votre assemblée notamment au regard
du calendrier européen tous les jours
dans nos départements dans nos communes
on ne peut mesurer l'impact de la
politique agricole commune
c'est bien entendu le secteur économique
dans lequel intégration communautaire
était la plus poussée et sur lequel
l'union européenne est consac une grande
partie de son budget ceci représente 43
% du budget total de l'union européenne
il est bon de rappeler que les
agriculteurs de france bénéficient des
aides extrêmement importante et il est
bien entendu important de distinguer
dans ce débat deux choses qui remontent
de toutes les interventions et sur
lesquels je crois il faut qu'on se
présente ici les aides directes du
premier pilier de la pac couple est
découplé ou dpu 70 % du budget de la pac
paiement unique par exploitation
accordée aux producteurs sur la base des
références historiques et plus
généralement selon les surfaces
d'exploitation sur la période 2007 2013
la france est le premier bénéficiaire
des dépenses relatives aux marchés
agricoles les agriculteurs français
reçoivent en effet autour de 10
milliards d'euros par an der agricoles
dont 85 % issus du premier pilier en
2010 la france a ainsi reçu c'est bon de
rappeler le chiffre 10 9% de l'ensemble
des crédits
il est aussi l'une l'un des plus gros
financeur puisque contributrice au
budget avec 21,9 milliards d'euros la
politique de développement rural
deuxièmement deuxième pilier de la pac
l'union européenne confie cofinance des
mesures qui contribuent au dynamisme
socio économique des territoires à la
préservation des paysages et ce à
hauteur de 25 % globalement du budget de
la pac
si la france semble bénéficier d'une
position de choix dans le domaine
agricole cette dernière doit être
protégé c'est tout l'objet des
négociations qui ont eu lieu ces
derniers ces jours derniers l'enjeu
étant de taille puisqu'il s'agissait de
définir l'impact pour les six ans à
venir 2014 2030 2020 pardon
malheureusement ceci s'est conclue par
une baisse de 7 3% par rapport à
l'enveloppé allouée pour 2007 2013
le nouveau budget de la pac c'est le
vent exactement à 373 milliards d'euros
désormais monsieur le ministre c'est
dans la traduction nationale que tout va
se jouer
et jamais sur ce sujet jamais le débat
national n'aura pour la suite des choses
n'aura été aussi importante
je pense également que parmi les points
délicats les fondamentaux il ya la
fameuse convergence concernant la
redistribution des aides
il a été choisi d'abandonner c'est
plutôt regrettable
sous la pression de certains gros pays
l'allemagne le plafonnement des aides
directes qui deviendrait ainsi
facultatif mais en échange le principe
de dégressivité sera appliquée une
convergence externes et internes
devraient ainsi conduire à plus de
justice
bien que pour le moment seul un accord
sur la convergence interne était trouvé
où semble-t-il
nous sommes favorables à une
distribution plus juste des aides afin
d'aider les plus petites exploitations
défavorisés par rapport aux plus grandes
ces dernières bénéficiant les chiffres
ont été prononcée à plusieurs reprises
de 80 % des aides directes actuellement
certes on n'oublie pas que les grandes
exploitations sont contributives à
l'économie et à la production de masse
de ce pays
nous restons toutefois attaché aux
principes que je viens d'énoncer en
vérité sur ce sujet la notion des 50
premiers hectares n'est pas rejeter le
débat national doit s'engager et nous y
sommes très ouverts
la solution se situera au bon point
d'équilibré entre la nécessité
impérieuse d'éviter la disparition
fatale des agriculteurs et la nécessaire
préservation de la production nationale
je regrette une orientation pro peut
marquer de mon point de vue en direction
de l'élevage et dont les perspectives
vous le savez tous mes choses ami est
extrêmement sont extrêmement morose
certes le ton pour les aides couplées a
été renforcée c'est une grande nouveauté
passant de 10 à 13% avec une possibilité
supplémentaire de 2
pour cent pour la production de
protéines végétales qui permettra de
soutenir le développement de l'autonomie
fourragère protéique d'un élevage ceci
accompagné d'un mécanisme de limitation
des pertes pour éviter les bains est
trop forte
pas plus de 30% et pour favoriser
l'emploi qui se trouvent davantage dans
les exploitations de petite et moyenne
taille serait institué une majoration
des heures de direct sur les premiers
hectares tout ceci est insuffisant ou au
moins perfectible il faut à tout prix
utiliser toutes les mesures disponibles
pour accorder le soutien maximum aux
exploitations d'élevage je parle d'abord
des bovins viande les leviers à utiliser
pour l'avenir bien entendu le couplage
on n'est peut-être pas arrivé au bout de
ce levier le levier des compensation du
handicap celui des mesures adaptées en
soutien de soutien en 2e pilier
les mesures à mettre en place pour les
bâtiments d'élevage ça vient d'être
évoquée et préserver le niveau de dpu
des système naisseur engraisseur
l'utilisation de ces leviers et le voilà
bien entendu pour la production laitière
sur la tendance actuelle le paysage de
la production laitière dans les dix ans
à venir va être totalement bouleversée
au point de mettre en péril
y compris l'approvisionnement de
l'industrie laitière la disparition des
élevages classes classiques ne
s'accompagne pas de formule de
remplacement
il y a donc sur ce sujet des signes très
forts a donné là encore nous vous
donnons rendez vous sur les ministres
notamment sur l'engagement donné par le
président de la république lors du salon
de l'agriculture
enfin je dis des mots sur une filière
qui est plutôt l'oublier de ces
négociations c'est la filière chevaline
un autre point fondamental non mais bon
là pour rigoler c'est pas mal aussi
c'est bien ça c'est vraiment gratos et
resto chez je répète à monsieur le
ministre il serait nécessaire et que la
filière chevaline ne soit pas l'oublié
de ces négociations parce que la filière
chevaline
elle est dans beaucoup de régions le
support de l'activité notamment dans des
zones défavorisées et des maisons de
deux montagnes
autre point fondamental est récurrent
qui ne peut pas ne pas être évoqués le
verdissement dont chacun d'entre nous a
parlé d'un tiers des aides directes
dépendra de la mise en oeuvre des bonnes
pratiques environnementales de base et
30% des aides indirectes rural
récompenseront pourrait-on dire ce
qu'ils feront plus l'effort pour la
biodiversité et le climat bien entendu
une agriculture éco-responsable et
souhaitable de plus de plus notre groupe
udc a d'ailleurs montré son intérêt pour
ce sujet en déposant une proposition de
résolution sur le droit européen pour le
consommateur ceci étant dit ne tombons
pas dans les clichés
regardons objectivement les efforts et
la contribution de nos agriculteurs à la
qualité de l'environnement ils font déjà
pour la plupart d'énormes efforts en
prêtant une grande attraction attention
à leur environnement
l'image de nos agriculteurs être souvent
déformée est loin de la réalité ce sont
eux en vérité les véritables protecteurs
de l'environnement il suffit de voir
l'évolution de la nature dans les zones
de grandes entreprises agricoles et
surtout un élément me semble
indispensable dans ce verdissement la
prise en compte des spécificités locales
et régionales
je pense en particulier à la soul man
qui n'est tout simplement pas possible
dans certaines zones
je me permets de citer le cas de
certains départements du sud ouest de la
france les landes les
pyrénées-atlantiques et d'autres où il
est impossible pour le moment de trouver
des solutions de substitution ou de
complément à la culture du maïs il est
absolument nécessaire d'adapter les
exigences environnementales en fonction
des départements de l'eure climat de
leurs caractéristiques agronomiques et
de leur caractère propre
autres sujets qui lui tiennent à coeur
li chn
vous vous imaginez les raisons et la
pêche à la prime herbagère
environnemental ce site où se livre le
fragile et sont bien entendu
indispensable dans leur maintien dernier
point que je voudrais évoquer la
question des jeunes agriculteurs
certaines avancées peuvent être saluée
comme l'obligation de majoration des
paiements directs
l'installation des agriculteurs est une
nécessité
de même ils deviennent de plus en plus
nécessaire de mieux accompagner c'est
une proposition dans les premières
années d'installation qui sont en fait
fondamental accompagner les agriculteurs
au niveau des risques et culture au et
les risques de marché
en conclusion monsieur le ministre le
temps de l'application de la réforme de
la pac en france est devenue beaucoup
plus je le répète que dans les années
passées la discussion nationale aura une
importance considérable de même monsieur
le ministre j'en profite pour vous dire
combien nos fonctionnaires régionaux et
départementaux notamment rattaché à la
vérité n auront besoin d'une plage de
responsabilité et d'initiatives accrue
l'application aveugle rigide des
dispositifs européens devient
insupportable regarder situation sur le
terrain enfin et ce sera ma conclusion
je voudrais vous alerter monsieur le
ministre sur la nécessité de régler les
distorsions de concurrence et le retour
à la compétitivité de nos entreprises à
l'heure actuelle des productions se
délocalise pour des raisons de dumping
social
c'était le cas de l'espagne c'est
maintenant le cas de l'allemagne cette
situation porte gravement atteinte à la
production agricole de france très
solennellement vous allez monsieur le
ministre et attendons votre vos réponses
sur le règlement des distorsions et le
retour à la compétitivité
merci merci chers collègues m
la parole est à monsieur alain bertrand
pour le groupe rdse
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
depuis un an le gouvernement s'est donc
mobilisée à bruxelles pour préserver
consolider la pac cette politique
essentielle européenne pour nos
territoires ruraux étaient en effet
contesté par certains notamment sur le
montant par certaines nos partenaires et
souffre et surtout d'un déficit de
légitimité
il est vrai que les arbitrages
intérieurs ont été faits pour garder ses
impératifs de compétitivité de
productivité au détriment de la prise en
compte de l'environnement des impacts
sur l'emploi de l'équité dans la
répartition des aides tout le monde de
la ville 80 % des aides revient à
seulement 20 % des agriculteurs
est il normal qu'un secteur qui profite
de prix mondiaux favorable nôtre c'est
pour certains ces dernières années
toucher des aides aussi massive
c'est bien difficile à faire comprendre
aux citoyens et aux agriculteurs
certains travaillent dur et n'arrivent
pas à vivre facilement en moins de leurs
activités je pense à toutes les zones
d'élevage que ce soit les vosges jura
les alpes les pyrénées le massif central
oui la bretagne aussi
aujourd'hui la nouvelle pac se dessine
mais il faudra voir les applications
nationales qui se veut plus juste plus
verte
il en faut mais point trop n'en faut la
priorité doit être une redistribution en
faveur de l'élevage et je reconnais que
le ministre stéphane le foll affiche
clairement ses priorités pour l'élevage
parce qu'il traverse une crise
exceptionnelle
tout le monde s'accorde sur la nécessité
de conforter ce secteur même le syndicat
majoritaire à moi qui suis le comice
agricole de benito 25 ans j'ai failli
tomber de la chaise d'ordinaire plus
protat défendre nos amis céréaliers
parce que c'est nos amis qui en a même
fait la défense de la garde et de
l'élevage une grande cause nationale
cette année le syndicat majoritaire
même si les prix se tiennent pour
certains oui je parle pas du lait
l'augmentation des charges et du coût d
une trame plus les aléas climatiques je
dirais cause de réelles difficultés aux
éleveurs
beaucoup sont tentés le ministre a dit
de se convertir vous l'avez tous si l'ol
2-2 l'idée agricole d'opposer les
productions les unes aux autres
mais simplement désisté sur la nécessité
de rééquilibrer les aides entre
productions végétales et production
animale il en va ni plus ni moins de
l'existence même de l'élevage dans pas
mal de régions européennes il en va
surtout de la reconnaissance du métier
d'éleveur de la dignité de l'emploi et
de nos paysages aussi je dirais que
parler de lui majeure et le ministre
adopté la cause des ravages
c'est adopter la cause de la rivalité de
l'hyper ruralité et des campagnes
françaises parce que derrière les
rivages il ya la vie de la possibilité
d'accueillir aussi les populations de
nouvelles la possibilité de créer les
emplois et la vie de 80% de notre
territoire français la convergence des
aides et le verdissement vont dans le
bon sens mais l'europe ne peut se
contenter d'une politique passive de
distribution des subventions
il est nos amis communistes round il est
indispensable de dépasser cette vision
pour porter une vision plus volontariste
l'agriculture qui préserve les
productions les plus fragiles et
soutiennent les zones défavorisées et
maintiennent aussi la diversité
nous quittons l hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance si
vous souhaitez la revoir ou en savoir
plus sur ce thème notre site internet
publicsenat.fr tout de suite hein c'est
à l'émission politique de la rédaction
de public sénat preuve par 3 qui reçoit
aujourd'hui l'ancien ministre et député
de la haute-loire laurent wauquiez bonne
soirée à tous